welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
that's right heel up thank you to
today's sponsors and the empty quip and
stitch fix next week's guest is the
great and wonderful rhett and Link of
good mythical morning I'm very excited
to have them they will be joining us on
Thursday at 7 p.m. PST an unusual time
please leave your questions for them on
the subreddit we will also be having an
extra episode this Tuesday top of the
bud joining us on the mic and sound war
will be the funny and wonderful good
friend of mine Zak Adel aka psychic
pebbles it's gonna be a magical mystery
ride so join us on Tuesday but enough
with that peripheral BS because today's
guest is perhaps the most underrated
youtuber of all time for sure of all
time his production quality is beyond
anything I've ever seen on YouTube and
every video has the production quality
and visual effects of like a
multi-million dollar Hollywood
production it's insane
he's been doing it for 10 years and he's
in my he's one of my favorite channels
and he's criminally under watched you
may know him as Captain disillusion he's
a superhero whose special power is
skepticism he debunks conspiracy
theories and faked special effects in a
wonderful comedic way that I have not
seen anywhere he is the incredible Randi
of the new generation I cannot sing his
praises enough and it is a great honor
and privilege to introduce the wonderful
Allen Melek Jane Ian to the show and
also Allen and viewers at home did you
realize that we're on a green screen
this whole time Oh who's the special
effects master now dude green-screen
ourselves into our own studio please
who's on that level I know how to drag
and drop ultra keys alright with that
being said I hope you all just got
freaked out
let's get wrong with our boy Allen got
him what did you think about that how
what do you think about our special
effects you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] Wow
okay that's what happens when you out
dock they don't know what you think
you're so smart but actually he's called
the amazing Randi all right so you got
that wrong incredible Randi
I'm sure he'll take incredible thank you
so much for being here god bless ya
great to see you thank you for having me
hi I think hi and everybody who's ever
seen your videos has got to be a huge
fan thank you so I it's great that we
finally get a chance to say what up I'm
so happy to be here I should warn you
guys though
that uh the the the first the only other
time I've been to LA before now has been
for like work reasons with this company
that I've been years ago
and we came here to get like an
endorsement from a famous person and our
experience was we came to LAX landed
went straight to Beverly Hills to meet
in the home of this like well-known film
director who was in our meeting but I'll
say another name though because during
the meeting which went fine it had to be
paused for a minute because he was
visited by rock musician guitarist Slash
which just showed up with a DVD of a
cartoon that he produced or something
that starts like a kid version of
himself that he wanted to show the
director so they watched it in his
bedroom like sitting on the bed yeah and
we're there watching them watch this
like a couple of kids and then you know
he they finished he left
we finished our meeting went back on the
plane so I'm just saying the level of
weirdness has to be maintained this trip
like if you guys can help me out so I
have a story each time is not an
uncommon experience no no he's a strange
city it's way too big
hmm there's everybody takes freeways
that are like you can't see anything
when you're on the freeway so you have
no grasp of what the city is actually
like a lot of people come here for
business
they just their experience is being
stuck in traffic all day and then they
leave they're like what's the yeah what
did I like it it's just you got a
you got it good understand like ten
years here be like yeah I'm gonna fall
in love with it yeah over time I get it
and I know it's not that romantic it's
not like I think you succeed here fall
in love yeah that's how it works
maybe my first question for you is how
long does it take to do that makeup used
to take a really long time like I was so
slow and bad at it it took me like maybe
like 45 minutes like it shouldn't look
like it takes that long but I got it
down to about 15-20 minutes when I'm
like just breezing through it that's
still it's it's a process and I imagine
like how many shoot days do you have per
visit I try to keep it to one for that
very reason but sometimes yeah we'll
have like a proper like movie shoot day
where it's like an 8 to 12 hour day
we're just like let's get because I do
12 takes of everything and I can't
really talk good so yeah we'll just
shoot everything through but sometimes
if it involves me like being in a
different location or something outside
the place so we'll we'll do like a
separate day so there's a lot of
planning that goes in through the script
probably because it's gotta be all right
I mean I treat treated like short films
you know like we do and I went to film
school we did little films all the time
and it's the whole I do everything by
the book that way I write the script
I'll plan it out do a shot list and Wow
do it in the nerdy way so when you say
well here I want I want to I would like
to for the uninitiated here in the
audience watch one of your videos I want
to just give the people out there who
aren't familiar with your work some is
that okay oh yeah I hope it's not one of
the old ones that I know I want to watch
your first video is like what the hell
like your first videos from ten years
ago and aren't all the other bought
videos at that time I bought a square
yeah mine's a square technically but
it's like letterbox to be 16 and now it
looks normal
yeah at a time you are I had to add a
special tag because it was like you know
how that the thing that happened where
like you had the widescreen video and if
you got boxed in twice right so there's
like a little tag they made you could
put it in and it's like
ahead of the freaking game even ten
years ago so okay I want people to get
the full D the big ol D that they
deserve no quick T's here
big fat D so here is your I think this
is your most recent video yeah you made
you you at home may no have heard of the
invisible box challenge I happen upon it
and basically what you do generally
speaking is fine online phenomenons or
how would you call it people who are
trying to get away the something yeah I
mean just hoaxes and a little depends
sometimes it could just be something
unusual and you can't tell if it's real
or fake or someone really deliberately
deliberately trying to like fool people
it's different thing or sometimes it's
just a viral ad right so you debunk
stuff videos essentially graphical
effects mainly yeah I like I just call
it debunking for ease of like
understanding but sometimes I'll just
like kind of critique a thing or say hey
here's how you could do this you know
and this is how they did it this is how
you could do it sometimes I'm really
pissed off and I think what they're
doing is wrong and I kind of really
criticized the people behind it
sometimes I'm having fun with it
when you say are you talking about the
character or yeah how what's the
difference between what you feel and
what the character feels I mean it's
like a heightened exaggerated version of
like my impulsive reactions to what I
see but of course it's made you know I
like to think I'm a nice guy this is
like how I wish like the dickish version
of me that I wish I could be and I think
it works just for comedic effect
sometimes it's like almost what not to
be
like how not to react it's you know it's
like a reverse like I love it I think I
think it's so funny I love the character
well here let's watch this first of all
let me say I love how you just flex on
all the people in this video because
you're like you guys were all doing this
fake box challenge but if you were good
this is how you would do it basically
let's watch
I think we should just go ahead and
pronounce the word meme the way we all
read it in our heads
I admit something embarrassing yeah
you're like my first two years on the
internet I said I said Mamie yeah me too
why I didn't talk on the internet but
that's how I thought it's pronounced how
would you how are you supposed to know
you were in is what you're supposed to
yeah you're supposed to hear the
audiobook of the Richard Dawkins book he
says no but I was I was chastised by my
friends because I was walking around
saying Mamie that's so embarrassing but
I was there like it's me Mom I should
bring it back yeah I mean it's more fun
to say little circle yeah the dank
maymay well you guys are trendsetters
now you could do this you brought it
back you're the main main guy it's a
perfect still there meme already means
mime in French so the viral trend we
call that should at least involve some
actual miming skills like for instance
the invisible box challenge you know the
thing that was a thing for a while where
you try to convincingly step over
nothing it truly took off when someone
actually managed to do it well was that
one fake no no that's that's okay that's
the one I saw like that's cool I mean
none of them are fake I mean there are a
few the ones that are highlight you know
yeah and it kind of came later the
phenomenon of faking it because people
wanted to one-up each other but first
people were just trying to do this dance
move which I guess she does the best do
it well and that someone was see your
Texas varsity cheerleader Arielle Olive
are here she is on NBC's Today Show
explaining how to perform the move in a
series of shots that break every
possible rule of composition let's watch
okay first you to show them as nothing
there
like a magic trick and then you lift
your leg or no you have to pass I
thought you were gonna do bunk this
place turns out you just didn't like the
well behind the scenes extra here you
see they have a little green screen
thing going on in that show because
later they do a joke of it the hosts
join her and they do it anyone can do it
well anyone who is strong lightweight
and extremely coordinated like Ariel and
me watch this your green screen setup
yeah well I made this like rigged up to
look sadder and fall it's incredible
what you can accomplish with relatively
small resources sure just gotta know how
to make it look good and notice the
green shirt on green green screen that
was not easy
what you mean green yeah before before
the green screen disappears it's
actually being keyed you gotta have the
skills understand exactly what I'm
looking at here like I'm wearing that
green shirt there everyone what is being
keyed on green screen for that little
bit and that's just you know that's just
how you just experience that skills
right oh my god Dan well how do you feel
about that are you insecure back there a
little bit we were struggling we were
struggling keying out that perfectly lit
professionally setup look good to me is
that it is that a good conditions for a
greener for a green yeah yeah we can't
really we can't really good
another part that I love the view in
door types how about this when you start
flexing on these haters and show how it
could really be done feel like much of a
challenge how about this my totally fake
invisible box video breaks all those
rules
the camera is handheld and moving a
clear shadow shows my foot not touching
anything and this alternate angle shows
I wasn't suspended from above
can you tell how I did it so when you
all reveal so great so how long did it
take you to actually as you go into the
details of how you did it and putting
dots on the concrete
okay after finding just the right
location completely and I filmed the
shot with a real box dotted with
tracking markers I also put a dense grid
of markers on the ground in front of the
box like all these markers help me
extract a camera salt and refill all the
dots in the back you set up like though
the back are just just features that are
dot looking but mainly what was
important is that area move in 3d much
more precisely than could be done with
auto tracking armed with this 3d
animated recreation I was able to freeze
one frame of the pavement without the
box which I made sure to capture right
after filming the move and projected
back on to the virtual ground surface
making the box literally invisible
throughout the moving shot forced it
also made everything else that entered
the area disappear and while the green
on the Box helped a little I ended up
manually rotoscoping my hand and foot
and their respective shadows to appear
on top of the box and visibility patch
ironically the biggest challenge was
removing the markers that made the
effect possible in the first place
painting them away in one frame and
using the same projection method as the
box wasn't enough because my shadow
moved across them so I picked individual
frames where various markers are in
shadow painted each one
and combined a series of projections
until I had a version of the entire grid
in shadow I then used the tracking data
to stabilize a 2d projection of my
shadow and rotoscope did to create a mat
that controlled when and how a shadow
moonwalkers revealed after SIA final
tweaks and color adjustments I ended up
with a pretty convincing take on a meme
that was already extremely out of date
when I started being trans out a couple
questions that was so great yeah that
was actually one of my favorite moments
from from your videos of how about that
whole sequence came together how long
did it did it take you to put all that
together well I I mean I take I release
a video a month and so you know that the
old like adage they a task is going to
take as long as the time you a lot for
it so it pretty much takes me every day
of the month to put it together but like
the effects are definitely the longest
portion because I'll shoot it in a day
like I said I'll do like the rough
editing in a day and then I just sit
there for days doing moving the fine
work so you you you spend the bulk of
your time doing all the visual effects
do you do you edit yourself yeah I
everything every like moment of every
video I've done on my own you know if I
was smart I could like collaborate with
people and get people to help me but you
know I'm still working on that I'm
figuring out how I can I can make that
someone on that level which could you
ever trust somebody else that edit ear
style just you just have to know how to
meet the right people and like you know
kind of find like minds and people of
the same skill level but I'm not like
you know what's funny as we were
watching that I wanted to say that yeah
it looks it's pretty dense and I'm
explaining a lot of stuff but honestly
like anyone that does visual effects
when they watch that they'll be like
yeah sure like that's what we do
nothing's what we do every day huh I
mean it's it's just that kind of
complicated like it's it's yeah but you
know it's funny well before I knew how
to edit I used to watch these like MLG
montages and I was like that's magic
it's like just really shitty meme
it's hunger but now that I see that it
looks really easy yeah but I'm
interested what you said about how it
takes you so long to make a video it's
so hard for you your video to be
relevant by the time you finish it do
you find yourself coming along that
problem frequently yeah I mean you know
that like YouTube move so fast is that
you're trying to hit on something trendy
so I'm I've learned that I just that's
not something I'm always able to do so
I'm like aiming for things either like
this I'll just play it off and say well
now it's my turn to talk about this or
I'll just pick things that are kind of
timeless like a lot of viral videos just
come around like you just come back then
they do like they're like a comment I
had an episode called viral comments
where it's just like stuff somebody just
starts sharing the thing from 2002 again
and it's like how did you tell me about
your background of visual effects and
special effects you studied it in
college but how did how did you actually
get good I didn't actually study visual
effects in college right I always was
interested in like moviemaking and
animation and it was always a toss-up
for me between which of those two fields
I'm really going to pursue and when it
was time to go to college
I picked this like kind of little like
dingy little film school that was just
starting out and and they had a computer
animation program that was all fancy and
this little like trihard little film
Department and then I signed up for
animation but at the last second like
after the first day of school I realized
I need to change my major because
animation and anything with visual
effects with computers that's something
you can learn on your own
honestly like there's especially now
this this was before like tutorials and
things but there were books on the
subjects and you could you could just
get the software and figure it out and
play with it until you figure out how it
works but with filmmaking shooting stuff
editing you've got a it's like a team
sport and if you don't learn in like a
safe way how to work together with
everybody how to delegate and everything
then you there's no and also like play
with all the fancy equipment that you
don't necessarily need
just can't get tons of money yeah so I
said yeah I spent like I studied that
properly and then I kind of just taught
self-taught in terms of effects in it
well so people who want to learn how to
do this or learn to make film is that
the important thing that you learned
from film school more than anything just
how to work in that that team
environment would you say yeah well like
specifically just things not with not
having to do with effects just making
movies telling stories that's something
it's difficult to do on your own you can
watch a YouTube tutorial about how to
work with a group it's not you can even
watch that tutorial but you without
experiencing it and like interacting and
getting a thing done together I don't
think you can you know you it's like you
just have to feel it out but a computer
program is a computer program like we
use them every day so this is just a
different thing you do that with a
different tool I wanted to ask you kind
of answered it is it possible to learn
to be that good at editing in school or
do you think someone who's who's as
talented as you at it see you grimacing
I don't take compliments well do you
think that someone can get that good at
something would have to just on their
own decide and dedicate I'm gonna spend
an obscene amount of time by myself
studying this on YouTube or wherever is
that the only way to get that good to
just study it on your own yeah maybe I
mean I I studied I was like a nerd about
it like when I was actually in high
school before college I was in this sort
of technical like progressive high
school that had almost like college
majors and they had a TV production like
studio and that's what I was in so I I'd
stay after school they had these editing
Suites with this new thing called the
Video Toaster which was like this is
before computer like nonlinear editing
it was like a computer an Amiga computer
that would run tape decks like to play
them in time and then like you could mix
it on the communities like this weird
technology but it also came with a 3d
program one of the earliest ones that
was available that wasn't like tens of
thousands of dollars so I said there and
watch like VHS tape tutorials of like
how to use it by this company and just
like nerd it out on it and
that I guess if you put in the extra
time you can accomplish anything you
know just that's it that's the whole
thing with my videos it's like nope my
my trademark is no one would spend that
much time on something so insignificant
and it's like I just do it I just push a
little bit further and then it looks
impressive to people I'm wondering so
what were your resources for learning
like did you actually learn from YouTube
tutorials and stuff like that well like
what I learned like predates tutorials
like I said like this is pre YouTube
days like pre 2000 yeah your first video
10 years ago was already edited like in
a similar fashion yeah I suppose and and
and I mean I literally would go to
bookstores they would have like fat
books on well that's that's the old
world dedication yeah and then yeah
tutorials their sites I did a talk the
the QED talk that I have I you know I go
a little bit over like the process of I
do things and there's some you know
there's a lot of online not just
tutorials on YouTube but there's like
sites dedicated like lynda.com that just
like have proper lessons lesson plans
and teach you and I frequent those I'm
subscribed on so many of those I don't
even know like I'm sometimes what are
you watching tutorials oh yeah because
this is it's so easy to that this the
tools change every day and they get
improved and even like if you just use
After Effects if you haven't updated it
in a few months you were like you don't
know all the new features they have like
now we do things completely different we
don't use that effect anymore which of
those websites would you say our lindo
like I said there's a there's a thing
called plural site it used to be called
digital tutors com that was plural site
it's also like a lot of different they
cover everything there's like a section
on like and you know programming or
whatever and then there's like just for
arts and digital effects it's kind of
the incredible thing of today is that
anyone who's dedicated can learn pretty
much anything on their own yeah and then
their sites that are dedicated more like
to specific tools like um
I'm kind of I've been frequenting and
become friends with a couple of people
from this site called CG kooky dot-com
and there they pretty much cover only
like analog regular arts visual art and
also this program called blender which
is like a free completely free what's it
called open-source like 3d software
package it actually does other things
like compositing and they're trying to
be like from start to end you could do
everything on it you could edit video
and stuff but it's mainly it gets
strength is 3d so you could do like
Pixar Animation level styling and you
just download it that's crazy
it's crazy and nobody has an excuse
anymore to not like be a professional at
whatever they want
I feel like mm-hmm you keep mentioning
how you put all this time in for
something insignificant this seems to be
a theme somehow what is the most
insignificant thing that you've spent
the longest time editing and how long
did it take you I think there's a lot of
examples the thing that popped into my
head now maybe it's not the most
ridiculous example but the the will sigh
video I did about the magician that was
on America's yeah I remember that yeah
there is he's got like online videos
where he uses like digital effects
instead of actual magic and so I was
trying to there was a quick montage
where I reverse engineer you know like
just display like here's what was really
happening in the shot
and sometimes I'm adding little elements
and and there's one where he does a
trick where he changes he has a ukulele
and he just like it's a it's like pink
or whatever and he flips it in it's
green or whatever color and I'm just
just to show that it's it was just like
blue or whatever it was a solid color
and just like with the green screen you
guys did he just keyed a different color
and then to show that though yeah yeah I
I'm I don't you know it's you the
YouTube video quality is not that good
like the compression sure if you're
zooming in on something like a ukulele
it's flat and you see all the artifacts
so I couldn't like key the thing he
keyed and do it over so instead I had to
rotoscope this ukulele and every string
of the ukulele like frame by frame
so the strings didn't change color
I could change the clothes painted in
and it was on the screen for like less
than a second for sure just for once
probably I watched that video how they
looked amazing yeah I mean it's it's
like if if it wasn't there if it wasn't
there maybe it wouldn't make a
difference but if I didn't do that one
and another little piece in another
before you know it it's not interesting
to look at that video actually rocked my
world a little bit when I realized that
America's it was America's Got Talent
right think so they were cohorts they
helped him cheat yeah that's what it
looks like I mean I don't know any other
explanation it's it's it's a big like I
guess claim but I mean I'm not making it
lightly it's like you look yeah there's
a cut there yeah there's a cut so unless
they did it maybe they did it for
YouTube or something I don't know but it
looks like the show it makes sense
though when you say it like that they
would do that yeah for people who
haven't seen it he does a trick he's on
like black velvet what was the trick
where you thought it's typical it's
called the coin matrix where you have
the four coins and you cover them and
then they end up magically showing up to
the same spot but he did like a flourish
on it where he he just made things like
instead of you know just manipulating
coins under cards he just like would
snap his fingers and they would just pop
into places and he transformed him into
petals rose petals and then like it just
it started out ordinary but then became
like amazing hmm and when he did these
transitions that look like the old movie
cut kind of effect it literally was that
or at least it was assisted by like a
little time compression a little cut
that implies a lot because they
presumably do it in front of a live
audience yeah well yeah in that case I
think what was happening is it was
pretty much what you see but they cut
out like a frame or two just to see some
kind of it's like there's some kind of
hatching I don't know what it looked
like I have no way of knowing but I can
imagine you know what probably happened
there like this looks so fake if you're
watching it's so obvious there without
consulting him probably and even they're
like let's let's fix this because it
looks horribly fake I think yeah
not even look that fake and maybe to the
audience watching it on the monitor and
screen and it would look fine sure but
if you're gonna put it on TV and on
YouTube you know people can get a
frame-by-frame so now you have no choice
so maybe they are like but I don't know
is that okay no I know it's like you
suck dude you can do it yeah just a risk
you know yeah people will see that
there's a thing for a frame that magic
isn't real you know just let them see I
love that like all of your videos and I
have to compliment you more work on that
let's let's take a quick break we are
gonna be back I want to talk about the
gateway to sidonis video I love that
there's so much in there so we are gonna
go to a quick commercial break and we
will be right back with yo boy the D
take a captain dissolution but I like to
call them the D so come get the D in a
minute thank you too and the empty
movement for sponsoring this week's
episode of the H Street podcast you guys
have heard me talking about MVM t you
know that it was started by two college
dropouts that started their own wash
company it's crazy how fast this
company's grown because they've sold
almost two million watches in over 160
countries and they continue to
revolutionize the fashion world because
they believe that style shouldn't break
the bank what these guys are doing are
selling high quality incredibly made
beautiful watches for a fraction of the
price that would cost you from one of
these traditional retailers I don't know
if you've checked out the site lately
but they have doubled the number of
watch styles and now are selling high
quality sunglasses and just introduced
women's bracelets ELA they have really
cool ones
when barbed wire barbed wire ooh careful
Oh dangerous a little spicy you may know
for all of you people who aren't lonely
ass this Valentine's Day
it is around the corner and it can be
hard to find that perfect gift but envy
empty is here to make it easy you can
buy your loved one a Valentine's Day
beautiful custom gift box which has a
watch and a bracelet
imagine your girlfriend Oh Ethan you
never do anything for me I'm not it's
not directed toward you just type that
well you never do I don't expect
anything he never does anything for me
for Valentine's Day all this said it oh
my god it cost a custom box shows up was
incredible beautifully sure that show
this look how beautiful this watches
with a bracelet it's like oh my god
guess who's getting it tonight boy maybe
I should get you that maybe you should
maybe I already did
honestly this is gonna be the perfect
Valentine's Day gift their bracelets are
the perfect complement to the watch
it's a beautiful to stack and wear them
together or if you just want a slick
beautiful watch go to nvm VMT dot-com /
h3 and today my friends only you will
get 15% off with free shipping and free
returns if you don't like the dang thing
so go to nvm t.com slash h3 and join the
movement there changing the world I love
their watches hit them up
thank you for sponsoring us next we have
crap you know I love quiff I can't stop
talking about quip it's an electric
toothbrush that is so freaking good it
should be in every house in America you
know what toothbrushes are already
expensive you go to the grocery store
for a good toothbrushes gonna need like
five bucks and then it wears out it's
too firm it messes up your gums who-who
is making this crap so quit came up with
a brilliant idea they're like you know
what we're gonna change the game we're
gonna disrupt this market yes I've been
watching shark tank look at this is an
electric toothbrush it only costs 25
bucks it lasts for months all you have
to do is change out the top it's made of
rubber and really soft wonderful
bristles you doesn't have any batteries
to change or anything and listen to this
that's the real deal
you hear that vibrations that's the real
deal and here's the beautiful thing it
goes for three minutes which is how long
you're supposed to be brushing that
nasty ass mouth ears and it turns off to
let you know hey guess what you're done
and you're good to go
and now you can breathe in anyone's face
because you've got the perfect breath
I hate stinky breath and this is my
favorite toothbrush ever made it and I'm
obsessed with oral hygiene so here's the
deal go to get quit go to get quick calm
slash h3 right now and get your first
refill pack for e with a quip electric
toothbrush they start at just 25 bucks
the toothbrush itself that's a free
refill pack free at get quick calm /h
Lee that's GE t qu IP comm slash h3 try
it out I guarantee you are gonna fall in
love with this toothbrush and you will
never look back I love it thank you to
quit for sponsoring us and finally
stitch fix man listen you know there's
always that guy in the room he's looking
slick he's looking great he's ready for
everything for anything and that takes a
certain skill set it takes a certain
focus an appreciation for fashion and
maybe a certain understanding that some
of us don't frankly have okay I'm not
the most fashionable guy in the world
but here's what stitch fix does that's
so cool it's the new way to shop for
clothes and it's unbelievably simple
just go to stitch fix comm and answer
some questions about your sizes what
styles you like and how much you want to
spend Styx fixed has clothes for every
guy and his style it's not just one type
guy look they've got everybody from me
to a guy who some melts steel real men I
don't know what guys like that wear
overalls will send you overalls I don't
know but they have styles for everyone
your personal stylist then use your
preference and the other information you
enter to select brand-new clothes for
you I like the it's your personal
stylist they call it I like to call your
virtual
friend or mom not mom girlfriend she's
like listen you slob you you look like
[ __ ] I think it's stylist is better it
sounds great but what it really is is
your girlfriend who's like I need to I
need you to look good except you don't
have the girlfriend
that's why you need stitch fix once you
get the girlfriend you don't need stitch
fix but we're trying to get you to that
point maybe your girlfriend does not
it's a great thing this is a great
product that anyway the items are
delivered right to your home you try
them on and you only pay for what you
keep so if you don't like some of them
send it back forget about it
just send anything you don't want back
shipping is free both ways unrelated to
the read get your fix on demand or sign
up to receive scheduled shipments guys
of all shapes sizes and budgets agree
defining your new style starts with
stitch fix try them out today you got
nothing to lose so here's the deal folks
oh I forgot you know what
hang on and here's the deal folks get
started now sis fix comm slash a string
you'll also get 25% off when you keep
all five of the items in your box
that's stitch fix comm slash h3 to get
started today that's stitch STI TCH fix
sis dot-com slash h3 go try now dan has
been wearing this sweater from stitch
fix I think you've been wearing that
pretty much every Friday since you
signed up yeah he'll love it it's this
is this sweater I mean look at this no
but on ironically you've been you've
been rockin they really nailed you they
now the podcast reducer would you call
it your virtual girlfriend or style oh
why not both and that's the way so thank
you Dan thank you to stitch fix guys if
you are in the market for some clothing
and a beautiful watch or a toothbrush
please consider supporting our sponsors
to help support the show thank you so
much let's get right back into it
nice how's it going everyone good having
a great what is today Friday right well
yes the podcast schedules become so
irregular that I yeah
we usually do every Friday mm-hmm but
obviously people's schedules are well I
made sure all right you're a Friday one
sec here guys just need to check
something something everyone check your
phones just somebody reference your
phones here for a minute
oh you're good on the thing I'm good
then are you good on the thing I think
we're all good on my brother said show
more of his videos if you can my brother
is watching mm-hmm well go to his
channel obviously watching video your
ass you're parroting you know you know
what's funny the the one you showed was
very like perniciously copyright claims
really not by the the girl the for the
cheerleader video and not by her she was
nice actually contacted her just to make
sure I can use her picture and she was
cool and she's anyway but there's you
know these like companies that are like
there's one called the word viral is in
it and like messy right they really
wanted to monetize my whole thing and it
was like a background you know the
multiple steps of yeah claim kind of
thing so went all the way
well they released it because you
destroyed eventually yeah what the
companies like that it's like their
whole business model right sure although
I don't know why they feel they need to
monetize 300,000 views or something but
it's also fine I understand I'm sure
they're doing it on like the author's
behalf or whatever and I don't know what
the they own it it's them
oh so they'd like to say one time yeah
right that's why I guess that makes
sense but I understand that they need to
police that if someone simply just you
know reuploads the thing if they you
know you had to explain to them like
this is this makes up
to person that video is six seconds long
I use four seconds of before the six
seconds and it's like two percent of my
whole video just full of original
content I don't think it's very fair
that's the beauty of copyright that's
insane for them to think that they can
claim the whole video yeah and I know
that they it's like one time okay you
see that it says the name of the video
you just flag it but I they had to look
at it again mm-hmm when I counterclaim I
watched it don't watch a ten minute
video and said yeah for this four
seconds we are definitely still in the
right but you're using it well first of
all I learned a lot about for you since
we were in a lawsuit involving fair use
but you're using it for textbooks
educational purpose it's like yeah I
would call that textbook fair use I mean
I don't know much about law and but but
but because 100% fair use technically if
you make a video and you something
unlicensed even for a split second I
guess legally they're entitled to take
your video mm-hmm but then you can you
can sort of claim the fair use thing and
should give your case of like why it
fits and they may or may not decide yeah
the laws are really unclear over the
years I mean I didn't know how fair what
I do is but I think it is the aspect of
it being a transformative work I try to
keep to that I mean I use it for context
it says II won we won we won our lawsuit
you know congratulating compliments no
no but I'm saying if we're fair use you
are you are lar what's what's greater
than fair you are beautiful you can take
that to the compound we actually have a
call from a fan of yours who has a
question for you oh cool so I'm gonna
bring in David here tomato you [ __ ]
donkey but Rick what's the game wait
what is that Jordan sorry guys wait how
you thought you could vanish
well wait yeah how did he get I tricked
how did you not recognize his name are
you kidding me
listen anybody you've got us you've got
a smooth brain in other words you've got
no ridges on your brain that's why
you're deficient that I can outrun you
well I can't smart you every stepping
away I want to hang out he's just so
captivated no no I just want to say real
quick please don't be mean to me I'm
just a child okay but I just want to say
really quick I think I think you're
still being a lot about well good Paul I
think he redeemed himself you spent over
1 billion dollars on the east bit
welcome Jordan Jordan what billion
dollars on suicide after what's on
suicide prevention after he came though
I just want a formal apology why well
first of all Jordan wasn't a billion
dollars as a million dollars I agree
that was generous but doesn't it seem
like billion dollars was it doesn't it
seem like it was a transparent PR effort
especially now after YouTube just
removed all of his monetization because
he was like torturing not torturing but
Allah can tell the day he was tell about
you [ __ ] pecker he was damn truth
solution here I want chapter disillusion
to the book you and your fraudulent lies
upon locate Paul the lives of the Slater
the hatred all right Jordan but just the
evil all he did do you have a question
for Alan what is it what I just want to
know why you think it's so bad he was
she tried to revive a dead rat people
say he was hurting the dead rest but
he's true I don't think she was she
wasn't working the rat like what do you
call those things didn't that paramedic
tried to help the red what are they
called defibrillators he was a feeble
aiding him he shot him with the taser
gun
he was the pretty was the preview later
the free sperm and you know and I'll say
what last a fiance I just want to
clarify what they I noticed a lot of
conspiracies that I've got a little
Theory my older book about what I've got
a little consent a little clear about
why you know why close and Paul and I
don't mean to sound it'll beat this out
a piece of edit gore
what is one kid Ian how did you let that
kid you know what I'm sorry for Ian he
he put on a voice when we screen him I'm
scared the last time he called he
threatened to have me assassinated with
bitcoins yeah he's an industrious kid
right I really thought this you guys had
this a little bit more together but it's
everything wrong here is the ins fault
he was our intern he's been elevated to
PA but I think I should call him in turn
kind of keep them in check
all right it's hard to come back from
that all right
Wow I'm all riled up just looking sorry
again I started again guys you were born
in Latvia in 1980 during the Soviet era
how do you know all these things about
me that's classified
[Laughter]
yes that's true what was it like for you
growing up in well tell me about your
your experience its yeah it's like I
have kind of an unusual combination of
things I'm I grew up yes I was born in
Latvia in Riga the capital city of
Latvia which is a was a republic of the
Soviet Union and now it's a country of
its own wet which it used to be
originally then became you know the
conglomerate that was the Soviet Union
and then became its own country again
and during the Soviet Union era is when
I was born there but I am NOT Latvian my
mom is Russian my dad is Armenian it was
also a Republic of the Soviet unit and
is also a country now mm-hm
and so yeah like I'm I lived in a place
it's sort of like when British people
live group were born and grew up in Hong
Kong you got it like I didn't have
anything to do culturally with a lot to
be more Russian yeah like Russian I
spoke Russian to my parents you speak
Russian still I do probably not as good
as I you know to a Russian as I should
but I can I can get by some yeah and and
I still speak to my family in Russian so
yeah and then like I would go sometimes
for my parents were circus performers
and they travel the ladder
did I mention that real yeah amazing
like the that's from like novels exotic
of bringing but I I would travel with
them they didn't they traveled like
around the country but the USSR is like
the entire Russia is pretty big now what
what is Russia it's like bigger than
Pluto surface area or something but it
was huger then because of all the
Republic's were included in so was this
monster or a country and they toured
everywhere because in Russia at the time
maybe still circus is a little more like
a high-class kind of it was like regular
circus and the Soviet Union was like
cirque du soleil here like it was like
this thing every major city had a circus
building like a proper little built
building for it and they would yeah my
parents were would tour with different
companies and I'd go with them
and when I went to school I'd stay in
like in Riga go to school the normal
school year
with my grandmother I would just live
you know in one place but then and
summer breaks I would still tour with my
parents so that's yeah I mean I look
forward to it this it was fun you know
there's other you feel like this
exclusive club because there's other
circus kids of other performers and you
get to like run backstage and hang out
and all the local townies are like these
like lame children we can run away from
them too the behind the scenes but part
of the circus and so your parents are
extreme athletes um well no the the act
that they did my dad was a circus
performer from young age and he was
first an acrobat yeah he was in an
acrobatic troupe then he became a
juggler and like a clown kind of sort of
comedy character a guy and he was in
partnership with this other famous kind
of comedian mime guy from the Soviet
Union and then he went out on his own
and then eventually my mom who was just
a like a medical school student he she
in Latvia he performed he toured in
Latvia ran away with insurance your dad
your mom literally ran off in joy
the circus yeah she quit Medical School
not just that's like the biggest
betrayal so wow that is pretty insane
yeah and together they had like a
hula-hoop act I don't know if you ever
seen this kind of thing where a woman
will do like a bunch of hula hoops and
do crazy like the Hat sort of a duo kind
of act where they would be these like
cowboys this cowboy duo and do like it's
sort of half comedy have sort of this
skill juggling demonstrate yeah I did
not expect that
had you come to here how did you come to
be here well like a lot of people from
that time from that era from that place
it's it wasn't that fun like there were
a lot of problems laughter yeah like me
as a child I actually don't have like
scary negative memories of the Soviet
Union it was like this little not little
but like this isolated sort of thing
where you don't know you have an inkling
of how the outside world is yeah and you
have a you have a clear inkling that
it's cooler and better like outside of
the country is Disneyworld and here it's
a little bit like the soap only looks
one way and everything you buy is one
kind of thing it's a little bit gray and
I find interesting even people living in
the u.s. are at the time know that it
was better because there's all there's
that powerful propaganda didn't make
that yeah rest of the world seemed scary
and bad yeah I think when I was growing
up in the eighties that was when it was
like the veil was falling away Britain
is still up yeah and people knew it's
better like people especially among
performers that's the only one of the
only kind of groups that would be able
to go outside the country like athletes
and stuff right you know they go with
like a little KGB agent in tow and there
was agents with you guys when you travel
no well like I said during my time
growing up they never went abroad but
like before I was born my dad try yeah
like traveled all over the world and
stuff on his own and he got they would
have like a an agent responsible for the
truth
so what was your dad's perspective on
the USSR having been outside the country
and everything he was always a kind of
like a wry kind of like rebel but not
like he wouldn't you know not that's
with anything yeah he would just be like
I don't there's every place even the
circuses the backstages of circus have
had like a red corner they called a red
room or whatever maybe my red room is
based on that it would be like where the
the communist party cuz everyone in the
country is part of the Communist Party
it would have little meetings like
related to party patriotic things and he
would never go to those things and
second I didn't take it seriously I just
read 1984 for the first time it's
incredible the parallels I mean it was
clearly based on on communist Russia I
think the book that makes but hearing
you talk about it really conjures
divisions of it yeah and it's strange
because I understand that stuff now but
as a kid like I didn't feel the ominous
nosov it I just thought like this is
where we are and the world is cooler
like it would be nice to go to America
one day and a lot of people thought that
way and they concocted plots to do it
like my parents did the old like that
movie what's it called um something on
the Hudson with Robin Williams where he
plays like a Russian guy that defects
and so they did a thing where they got
into a situation where they could go and
tour in America and then they just just
asked for political asylum and Moscow on
the Hudson yeah so they but they did it
a little bit risky because they had me
and I left they decided the safest way
to do this is leave me behind
yeah and go if they had some friends
like another performer pair that did
this earlier in the early 80s they so
they had this contact out here and they
helped him arrange that stuff and then
they went they knew that they'd be gone
for two years
having left me behind and they would get
asylum they would get proper status and
then they would hopefully the way the
rules worked they knew that they would
allow them to have their child
everybody kind of banked on this
working and they did so did you know why
they were yeah I mean I understood I was
not all of eleven I came here at 12
years old
so like two years prior to that I guess
I was ten and they understood it but I
was too little to to be too freaked out
about it I guess I was like this that's
the plan yeah I'll just wait and then
for two years unbelievable and then
eventually the call came and I was kind
of like I also had no reservations I was
sure like yeah my my mom and dad are
getting me I'm going to America so
everybody in my like school and
everything I was like yeah you guys you
guys enjoy this while it lasts it's
gonna be gone and then you know I could
have not hello yeah they've been
horrible but incredible luckily it
worked out Wow and then you came here
and you had like a million kinds of so
it was overwhelming I mean my parents
were sending pictures of like what a
supermarket looks like and it was just
like that's so that's too colorful
really like I don't know how to perceive
this so how what was it tell me about
how you came to be here when you got the
call and what was it like when you
arrived here my well I kind of became
like I mean I loved American movies and
things I knew American culture I had
like a book called America like a cool
Illustrated photo photo like journal by
some somebody you weren't supposed to
have that right no I mean at that time
it was like the lines became blurred
because the thing was if it wasn't a
sudden thing that the Soviet Union fell
apart it was like happening it ended up
being like we are Soviet Union but
really nobody cares like weird we're
about to fall apart yeah so then you
arrived yeah tell me tell me about the
process yeah they as my parents were
trying to do whatever it is they were
doing getting like legal resident status
here and they were still performing with
little like fun fairs and circus things
here and I meanwhile was just in school
but on television every day they started
showing these parlamento whatever like
the Kremlin you know meetings of the
party and I'm figuring out how what do
we do the thing is falling apart what do
we how do we reorganize
troika you know that wasn't only
relevant yeah I was like every day all
day they would just broadcast the
Proceedings of them voting on things by
raising their hands and I didn't open
yeah I guess that's strange right but it
did it just shows that it was this
strange process where everybody in the
country I guess was just like over
everything and they just wanted answers
and they wanted to know what's what are
we gonna be now how's this gonna work so
they just started showing people the
process and but nothing was changing
like other than like weird feeling of a
little bit of like a wartime thing where
like sugar became like a rare commodity
you had to have like little tickets to
get your ration of things like sugar or
other products right it didn't really
change that much because if Russia was
always Soviet Union just felt like nice
and gray and simple and it just stayed
that way but and like whereas I grew up
with like uniforms in school and this
very like proper thing that started to
relax they started letting us wear
whatever we want and I didn't have to be
the pioneer anymore they had these
rankings as a kid when you're reached
like third grade or whatever you get
this little pin this little star with
Lenin on it and your little I don't know
how to translate it it's like October X
you know you're like because October is
a month that Lenin was born in and now
you have that and then you when you go
to a certain class level you become a
pioneer you get this read like the
Japanese students like a red scarf and
you do take a little pledge and this is
the doctrine yeah and it was very like
strict and everybody wore the same
uniform there was like two kinds of
uniforms in the entire ginormous country
and everybody wore the same thing but
then they started to relax especially in
a place like Latvia which was like
thinking oh Soviet Union's falling apart
we better ramp up our own culture again
we guys are on the outskirts I don't
know if that matters yeah well what do
you mean like and you weren't like the
heartland you yeah you guys were like
exactly became like all those kind of
Baltic countries we're like okay we're
gonna be European now
yeah that seemed instantly better and
now if you go to Latvia it's very like
it's like a Europe it's like going to
Paris or something right and Russia is
not like that it's a little different so
what were they saying so when you when
you how did transition when you got how
did it happen that you got the call you
said yeah we literally it was a call
they decided they they asked that I be
allowed to join them and they got the
document that said that that's okay and
then my grandfather traveled with me to
just on a flight you know and we took
Finnair is the Finnish airline that goes
it goes across the ocean and I on the
flight there I got a little you know
they give you little souvenirs and
things when you were a kid and they gave
me a little Finnair keychain and I have
that to this day which are like I landed
on the in America with that in hand and
I could just kind of keep it in my keys
that's wonderful
when you arrived in America and you got
off the plane was it a shock to you what
you saw and there like you said the
grocery store was so colorful yeah I
mean I and just as an impressionable kid
like I liked like I said like American
movies things and I just had this almost
idealized view which wasn't justified
but also like physically how America
looked it it really created that
illusion where did you land in an JFK
and so yeah my dad had to we're and live
in Miami lived I mean I still live in
North Miami but um
he had to drive the this old Ford
Econoline van of 1984 van that barely
worked you had to drive it up to New
York that is us somehow there's no cell
phones there's no nothing so how we knew
that it looked like it seemed like in
retrospect pure chance cuz we did I
spoke I learned some English just in
preparation but I wasn't exactly like
well-versed my grandfather didn't speak
English at all we didn't know where we
were we had to get through you know the
passport control and everything and
somehow I just we found the word like
yeah it work out some unbelievable so
New York when you got off the plane cuz
that's quite a grand arrival to New York
City how did the city look to you it
felt exactly like the scene I know I
people that watch my channel know like
I'm too obsessed and talk about back to
the future to me I was going to ask
about so like the you know the scene in
bar 2 when he first kind of goes onto
the square and sees the future like yeah
things look that that's how it felt to
me literally that's what I was thinking
of that was already like it was like
this insane I don't know I mean I'm sure
now if I saw that imagery again I'd be
like what a crappy like say you know
everything but but then it was like this
barrage of just everything is like clean
and sleek and colorful and it was really
we just like Iran it was the weather was
kind of like cold and and unpleasant but
even though that was happening I was
like wow and we just ran to the van and
just got on the road was there anything
disappointing about America since you
had idealized it so much um no not right
away cuz I think I was still a kid and I
was you know I wasn't like really
exposed straight to the realities of
everyday life I was just like oh I'm I
get to see my parents again great yeah
we have a house and we're renting a
house and yeah I was just it was really
great first few months a couple of
months where I was like cool I get to be
here now and everything seems awesome
that is a wonderful story thank you for
sharing that that was really great thank
you I want to I was it's funny that you
mentioned the Back to the Future thing I
with my next question why are you so
obsessed with Back to the Future
they're great okay they're classics
right but you're you're an FX guy yeah
or I mean there's there's so much stuff
you're interested what what is it about
those movies that you like well I mean I
just like them as movies and also you
know we all have the thing that we saw
at the right time and the right moment
just crystallize the only movie like but
yeah it's just easy because they just
remained so perfectly liked and they are
so American yeah exactly like I was just
like all about like the one had like a
male like the typical American mailbox
you know that shaved this sort of thing
I was like I want to have that someday
with the devil now a little stick we had
that in
that I arrived I don't have one now I
just have a boy like I'm glad you had
that though you were able to enjoy
having that as a kid yeah yeah I missed
those men you put the little red arrow
up yeah research what does that mean
what is that for cuz mail people didn't
pick up mail from your house it's like
so all the mailboxes on the street have
a little red I don't know how to
describe it's like it's a flag so when
you have mail in there that you want to
send out you put up the little red flag
knows that you should pick something
Healthcare red flag that was like an a
Mickey Mouse comic little things
what movie has your favorite visual
effects in CGI I saw that in the the
thread that people ask that I it's hard
to judge because I like effects for
different reasons like sometimes the
most awesome effects is the stuff you
don't see and all this stuff that's
invisible sharing a movie like Forrest
Gump the one came out at the time was
like this is sort of like a regular
drama human drama but there's like a ton
of visual effects early just amazing
hair I mean that the feather scenes
oh yeah the starting with the feather
words what else was there stuff yeah and
just a lot of they do a lot of touch-ups
unlike when he's on hey that's Robert
Zeca mess your van
I can't yeah I'm like yeah what I need
to think of something else because like
yeah what's a by the way no I love for
Scott I love when I first went to see
Forrest Gump in the theater I didn't
know anything about it no was about
everyone was just like oh I was like
what the [ __ ] that name is so stupid
what am I going to watch I came out and
I was just like yeah that was my oh my
god I'm blown away it's someone you can
just avoid every piece of information I
yeah that that rarely happens now like
it I think the last time that happened
to me was
Slumdog Millionaire I was like somebody
said oh let's go to movies and there's
this thing and I never heard of it and I
was it was very affected by it and I
don't know like maybe
purely like I don't know do you like
that movie like some people don't like
yeah yeah I like it it's like it was
really when you go in fresh it's like
and and then it happened to me the first
time I saw the Titanic sometimes we
would just go out the friends at night
and so you'd go to see a movie so it was
all about like we're going out with
friends I didn't even care what we were
doing watching this movie Titanic I know
did you come out in love with Leo you're
like she could have scooted it over a
little bit but it's weird
over time it's still a great movie but I
feel like all the time people like it
less for some reason it's well I think
it's more of a thing of like it's become
a cliche and you haven't seen yet
forever like Titanic but when you
watching that it's great any James
Cameron is another one of those
directors that's like I I struggled to
find something he that's not awesome
that he's done maybe have a question but
no but I didn't like avatar at all but I
really appreciated the work that they
put into it it's like whatever he takes
on he just like does it a hundred
percent incredible like the storytelling
part and he's like I would say like more
than Zemeckis even who Zemeckis is known
for effects films but I don't think when
you listen to him talk about this stuff
he doesn't he's like hands off on the
effects he works with awesome people
like he did Who Framed Roger Rabbit I'm
sure he did not learn everything there
is to know about the animation but he
knows like how to delegate that stuff
but James Cameron I feel like he
understands all of the stuff he's like
he'll be like over the shoulder of the
effects people of the senate's I mean
sometimes you see him with the camera
he'll like action sequences do you ever
want to make a movie what is your dream
I agreed well first I let's say like a
blockbuster yeah yeah but my only
experience is making a feature-length
film is right out of college
I worked a couple of times with this
Russian director who came would come
here and like do these super cheap like
B movies with like he'd bring aging
Soviet Union era like stars of the
screen really she's like for cheap at
that time you know after Soviet Union
and he would bring him do these like
super corny like raunchy romantic
comedies in Miami
and and I helped him a few times and
like because he just use whoever like
locally and I spoke Russian so and then
we're like that's what people in Russia
watched he's like awful awful like
directive video made on video looking
things so my dad and I were like hey
that's a way to do something let's make
this kind of corny Russian movie but
like with a little bit of professional
American Ben right and so we made this
this kind of like super cheesy for the
Russian audience yeah like we were
hoping to sell it to like Russian
there's Russian channels in America but
also maybe there and then like we sort
of overreached and under reached at the
same time like we made it to silly and
also weirdly like cinema graphically
sophisticated and it's just it was this
Hopf hodgepodge that wasn't appealing to
anyone so I made this feature film the
you know about like a Russian family and
America you know whatever with the
typical thing you would think of what
that movie would be and it was I don't
know it's like a thing I'd like oh god I
can't believe I watch that no I used to
be an Amazon but not anymore and you
know why it's all I feel like that could
have been a hit visited and maybe like
it well it was parts of it that were
English they were like Russian people
talking to Americans so it's like
there's a Russian version of a there's
an English version of it and no trust me
you don't want alternate universe that's
a that's everybody in Russia yes you
know I mean depends on how what I
accomplished in my life maybe then it
would be this weird relic if I look at
what how he started out a little this
horrible thing what's your dream like it
were in ten years what what is your
dream I my dream was cheesy I would like
to direct just feature feature film
now shows well see it's funny like all
my life I wanted to just be a film
director but now it's like we've reached
this age where I'm so burly trying to
look at it and I'm like cinematic films
like that's almost on the way out it's
weird like it's they don't make the
money it's hard to put that together you
have to basically be already in
Hollywood like it's what about a show
like yeah well science show like a
Netflix thing like Netflix is awesome if
I had anything a one-off kind of movie
or a show on Netflix that would be like
I think I would just hang up my has
nobody ever offered you a television
show or anything like that yeah it's it
has YouTube ever acknowledged you in any
way at all well I got the silver plate
but the gold no the gold which one is
the hundred thousand no is that one that
one's like a bigger one right it's some
yes pretty big yeah can you drag ours in
here okay um I want to see a television
show from you it already feels like it
when I watch one of your videos I feel
like I'm watching a TV show well the
thing is you won't easily be on Netflix
but I mean I don't know why I'm doing it
but I am doing it by like the rules of
like I used to even like compose the
shots where you know how now when you
shoot shows you it's sixteen by nine
screen but they shoot it so that old
grannies with squared TVs still can see
every important element so I used to
frame my stuff that way and have like
titles make-believe yeah and I even now
like the soundtrack that I do it in a
way that you could take out the dialogue
sometimes for patrons I actually do that
like here's the no dialogue version of
what you achieve by yourself with the
support of your patrons of which I am
one yes I saw that thank you so much
welcome in anyone out here who would
like to support Alan please go to his
patron I'll put the link in description
but what you accomplished by yourself is
like beyond anything I can even think of
on television that's not like you know
has like a hundred person
we're in a golden age of television the
hell is going on how do I feel like I I
want a fun we got to figure this out
because then I might want to figure this
out I'm on the Hornet we're gonna figure
it Dan and while your uncle Netflix not
that I have any idea for a show but I
just want to talk to them
we got to get you a show all right I am
down what kind of what kind of budget
DNA well we can talk about you know I
actually I have a friend who we talked
about this with like he's sort of
accomplished some things he's a fairly
like established music video director
and like Latin music market and we were
like yeah we got to do we got time's
running out we're good how much you need
for a pilot I don't have those figures
together and give it to but yeah like
that's what--that's we stopped where no
seriously like there's different things
I mean I've talked to people about is
there a captain disillusion proper show
format thing or can this just be like is
the character or something as a thing
you know maybe some kind of fictional
universe and things maybe it's not a
skeptic thing I don't know like I would
just like I I don't think I'm that
interested in being like an educational
guy like my channel I've never looked at
it as an education and it's not quite
either
it'd be hard to carry that character
yeah through 22 minutes but I think
maybe it would work good as like a host
in a second yeah yeah variety could be
but you know actually now you reminded
me like a thing I've repressed in my
mind I did have I did have a not a
meeting but a call once if I forget what
the network was but it was somebody it
was not Netflix but it was like a
television network or yeah I don't want
to say the wrong one but they they
called me they wanted to just like this
sort of probe little like talent scout
thing like hey we like you we think
you're you know whatever we want to talk
to you whatever it is what do you want
to do what's the thing and then I will
suddenly put
this conference call where they had like
producers and and talent people and
whatever you know and I was like meekly
talked to them and I did my best but
then I never heard from me I don't pop
on the phone you know I got that when
they put you under the gun like yeah it
was somebody it was a cool learning
experience think you just have to have
the thing in hand and you have to
explode at them and yeah you have you
have I've learned you need to over you
need to disgustingly over so you have to
be you have to feel ashamed when you
come out I guess that makes sense you
have to be like I'm such a [ __ ] for
saying that those things about myself
you know yeah well you know I every
every time that happens I learned a
little circuit alright we'll take this
conversation further off scare off the
record but six months you're gonna be on
that I want to shift the topic a little
bit here is some pictures from the
recent Superman films of which I hate it
by the way just for the record I thought
they were so awful and there's some
there's such great lore about Superman
and they've done some great things with
with like I loved Batman the original
trilogy with Christian Bale I was hoping
for some real storytelling but this
movie was just a real [ __ ] stinker
you know I hated it I have not heard any
good things it starts on May first on
and there's like all these animals
zipping around it's insane
regardless he they had to do research
for the reshoots for the movie and he
had grown a mustache now for another
film they're like no problem we'll edit
it out well the worst decision ever made
this one is even better I think yeah
that's going on there no is this a bad
job or is this just like almost
impossible to do good well yeah I want
to say I don't I don't know the movie
and I don't think it's good and I don't
know why it's such an insane concept
that they would do this like it's not a
practical approach no but I have to say
like I think we're hey
on it I mean yeah not the best not the
best frame but I mean once you're once
this is the rules of the game he has a
mustache you have to replace it I think
they did the best as good as you can
yeah like and some of it we have to
admit like we know what was done we are
primed for it sure it's like a big
difference yeah like in the the old dude
in the rogue one like everybody knew
everything about the fact that this is a
digital character and everybody you know
was like uncanny valley yeah yeah yeah
but might like my girlfriend doesn't
care about Star Wars and she didn't know
about the digital character we watched
them it was she had no idea it was
honestly I thought really well done yeah
there's some poor son of a [ __ ] at home
who's like I spent 10,000 hours yeah on
that one thing well they had that wasn't
somebody someone did an AMA on reddit
who claimed to be I don't know I read
that whole thing and I was like is he
for real or not I wasn't I just couldn't
come to a decision if he's probably fake
yeah the way the way he talked about
something seemed a little fake to me
here I want to go back and now as you've
explicitly said hopefully not something
old and should have kept my mouth shut I
want to go back 10 years to you're a
very first video now what strikes me
about this video and it's short but I
want to watch it with everybody just to
give you the the glorious history of the
D can I call you the deed does anyone
else call you that that's fine they call
me all kinds of things what strikes me
about this is first of all it's ten
years old which is pretty much 11 No so
that's like as old as YouTube gets
really all the videos back then were
square somehow yours is a rectangle we
talked about that already that was
surprising
second of all the characters like fully
developed already the character the lore
the corner you've already developed it
from this first episode that in itself
is an illusion because I didn't know
what I was doing I just made a thing
that looked like a thing that already
exists and that was the point it was
like we're cutting into a thing that's a
established show but it wasn't I didn't
know there was no plan like I just in
fact this is the things I say in this
video the script of it was written like
a wild bag before I discovered YouTube
it was like a blog post I did in my
space I would do dumb things for friends
on MySpace just like her and I just rode
that in the voice of this captain
disillusion character I didn't know what
it would look like what what the point
is I just thought just I wanted sounds
sarcastic and talked about this penguin
thing and I just did it in terms of like
in in the form of stills and then I when
I got on YouTube and I tried a couple of
stupid things and nothing you know was
really catching on and I thought like
what's another weird thing I have so I
dug up that blog post and I thought how
can I make it look weird what do I have
what if I was silver like that well I
have this weird mustard looking jacket
I'll wear that I'll have you I'll get
silver makeup and then I put on the
silver and I realized that's too much
I'm not gonna put it all over my eyes
and stuff so I'll just do halfway and
maybe it'll be a half face but then I
did it so messy I'm like I have to fix
this I've put black on and I try to make
straight lines but the lines were
straight only on the top so I'm like
okay I'll just finger painting this it's
like a dripping thing and then it looks
like every detail was perfectly executed
plan like Marcus with Star Wars you know
it was all part of a big plan right is
that sarcastic yes yeah let's make sure
let's watch this
by the way and reading and it was at a
time when the max quality you can get
his 240 PR and we've got it and look I
mean come on it's it's I'm sorry
but here you can watch it in double the
resolution double for a nobody's got you
can buy it on TV that's digital media
where do we poor wee thing
well my website cam the decisions are
common I'm honestly I'm trying to get
rid of the stock of these awesome items
I will have better shirts not soon
these are nice but this is awesome
things coming awesome things it's me
captain disillusion you know looking at
the world in an objective and empirical
way is key to a healthy and
well-balanced life
tone get me wrong dreaming wishing and
holding that back come on like they say
my human nature
am I talking in his emotion of disbelief
is why don't I just talk normal
it seems like you the background is that
it's for kids right yeah like well yeah
like the premise that it's a fake show
for kids but not it's not meant for kids
yeah like it's not meant for a
particular audience I guess it's a
parody of a kids show but yes I mean
yeah go ahead no difference between
belief and reality reality is real your
beliefs are in your head oh yeah well I
saw that cut and I was like really I
fail really Alan look I eleven years ago
I was still getting my sea legs with
this no our first videos you don't even
want you didn't use it you really can't
even watch down here and it's it's
actually illegal there's some things on
there that internet you've probably come
across this hilarious little video of a
penguin [ __ ] slapping another lady
looks like the player back then yeah
penguins so you're there anything they
can't do well actually there is this
exact thing you just saw boys and girls
when you watch that you do realize that
the video is fake right I asked because
the footage is posted dozens of times
over on YouTube what do you hate about
it just the way the performance like why
why is it like that and why hasn't it
improved that much since then you
started way too good and on many other
sites people use it as a profile picture
and yet I have never not once seen a
single comment proposed that the video
might be an artificial so so what what
inspired you to finally be like you know
I'm gonna make a video about this thing
was it were you that charged up about
people thinking this was real I was
charged up I think I was probably kind
of charged up when I rode the thing back
in the day before I made the video the
blood even think yeah just the blog
thing but I I bet I was just like
charged up for a second like a lot of
ideas I get for videos I'm I get annoyed
by something like in passing and then
I'll embrace that feeling and like by
the time I'm making the video I'm like I
don't care this is the this is the
conceit of this so yeah that's probably
what happened and at the time I mean
this it's funny to look at this part
because it's true what I'm saying that
was an era 2007 was like there would be
these weird gifts and weird videos and
people were buying it like a lot like
nobody even knew really that you could
fake something like that yeah I mean
they didn't that's not the first thing
that came to your mind you're just like
oh the internet is showing me things I
have sweet and innocent yeah and so it
was very fitting like at the time but
now it's it's like the opposite it
inverted it's like everybody's yeah
sending me such a video suggestions of
like somebody's like juggling I'm like
and they're like this can't be real
right he's juggling five balls like I'm
like yeah that's real well have you
never seen have you not gone to a circus
and seeing somebody through
I follow five clubs what do you think
about the what do you think about the
fact that we're now also skeptical do
you think that that's a problem in
another way
yeah well it's not I would almost not
call it skeptical is just like
pretending to be like emulating the vibe
of being a skeptical critical thinking
person like it's it's in now maybe the
skepticism movement succeeded too much
and now it's become like this like it's
cool to just not believe anything and
that's not productive it's more like
being a contrarian yeah like you can
follow off the other side of it and so
it's important to think about the fact
it's not about how you're reacting to
stuff or like it's not it's not about
having an opinion on a thing it's about
like filtering the way you receive the
information like you always think the
controversial things come to us in news
stories and posts you know and and it's
like it's always amped up a little bit
and you got to always step back from you
know like all the recent like new deep
fake and whatever things like it's
concerning it's interesting I want to
ask you about those but like the way we
always receive it is like a punch in the
face like did you know that the thing
that Hollywood art is needed millions of
dollars and teams of people to do can
now be done by one nerd in a room with a
pressing a button like that's not what's
happening but that's how we perceive
that's how we receive all these stories
and it's being skeptical as has become
about like I'm gonna filter all the
sensationalism away you just look at the
real problem and what do I think about
this how does it fit into the whole just
by the way this video viewed do people
watch this video
um I don't well yeah I mean I started
making more because it got caught on a
little bit maybe caught on meaning like
I went over the 300 view threshold at
the time what a reaction people like
yeah and so I I have probably took like
two months to make another one and just
to come up with a thing and then a third
one and then after the three like I
think whoever stumbled upon them notice
that there is a series thing going on
and that that started giving them all of
them views like they got best around
right right right
and at that point I think actually after
the first one I guess I had the
foresight because I posted it on my
personal little YouTube channel first
and then I'm like yeah I'm making a
channel for this this guy's huge and I
before I knew that that would happen I
made a channel and that's that's the way
you're seeing God the real video
probably got posted like a couple of
months before let me just show finish it
so that the people at home can see how
polished it was from day one God special
effect and that worries me so I'm gonna
break it down for you the video is
actually of one penguin walking across a
thin patch of ice and falling through it
the other element actually in certain if
I scene with compartir good you can
easily tell he's fake if you look at the
shadows of the two penguins as they
intersect one is darker than the other
in reality the only one who's like gives
myself you know like I would do the same
thing in tracking an animation of a
slapping wing is created and the whole
thing is rotoscoped or traced to appear
behind how could anyone believe that
honestly I guess back then we are just
sweet innocent but it's like so obvious
to us now yeah I mean maybe maybe I was
exaggerating and maybe there were people
that were doubting it in the comments
but I definitely saw a ton more leaving
then I would ever see I agree but I
guess someone very clever thought that
they could knock it up a notch would you
just like I think rolling on the corner
like you just shot up some heroin oh
yeah that was kind of like the thing I
was going for I was just thought like
maybe this would be darker and again
yeah but then it kind of became a little
more Disney somehow I don't know know
what happened well yeah it's well I
think it's hard to keep up like the
heroin addict I think of that yeah I was
thinking I was channeling like I
remember I liked the beginning of the
MTV show of the max the animated series
based on that comic book I don't know if
you ever heard of it
really cool as back like the 90s thing
but anyway
it began with this cool like push into
this dark alley
just like they made a comic book look
you know like a cartoon and it was like
it's awesome and healed it's like this
hobo that thought he was a superhero and
he lived in a box and so I was doing
some I see that yeah I see that
does it ever frustrate you that after 10
or 11 years now almost of making like
really incredible high production
content that you spent months on they've
never been acknowledged like officially
by YouTube and that like people like
Logan and Jake Paul are such huge thing
I don't sound like I'm above that but
honestly no because like I my I think my
brain it maybe my brains in the wrong
place but I'm always like I'm I've been
so resistant to all the YouTube culture
even that guy's not I wouldn't put like
what's called the end end card and cards
on my videos for like the longest
longest time and everybody already
figured that out
yeah and it's only now that they have
the feature for it I do a little thing
and I only want to really push people to
patreon cuz that's like the main thing
and I don't I try not to like ask for
subscribers and things and not that
there's anything wrong with that but
that's just like my weird hang-up like I
want to I want to feel like I'm making
little movies and being creative and
putting these little like little work of
art on paper ixnay
yeah
even comment like the video right I
don't I though the longer I'm doing this
the more I realized there's no reason
not to like that it's fine like that's
how it works and if you're smart that's
how you do it but I don't know I'm
trying trying to like walk that line and
be a little bit like no I totally get it
but it like I think there's a line for
sure where you can not compromise but
also help yourself yeah but I've noticed
I've noticed you been doing a better job
of it you've been on Reddit a lot a lot
I love there
I think your channel is it's due for a
yessum I am soldier I have to I can't
get complacent I have a tendency to just
get complacent with things I'm not like
a mover shaker so I once in a while I'll
do this Glacial move of when I started
my patreon that was like the last time I
did something okay I have this plan I'm
gonna make up these pledges that make
this introductory video and I just did a
bunch of things and I did it and it's
working like I set up this machine yeah
yeah but I haven't done anything like
I'm not like constantly evaluating I
don't know how to read my analytics it's
like I don't know okay 90% men 2 percent
yeah well I'm sure that there are ways
they're smart ways Susan of everybody's
always talking about them I just have to
you know either do a better job of it or
get with the person that you know is
someone that is good at that side of
things and make it like a partnership
where they just may tell me what to do
like here's how you'd be better at all
the stuff YouTube's worried I feel like
grunt coming up we were super obsessed
with like analytics and stuff and like
get it doing the right thing to get more
subscribers but now I feel like no that
stuff really matters it's just really a
matter of if the YouTube algorithm likes
your content and wants to promote it
yeah I guess it comes down to that now I
I wouldn't know like I really don't know
I don't understand why it's still such a
mystery like why are why don't we know
how it works this is all we do like we
should kind of know I think the real
secret is that even people at YouTube
don't know how it works because now it's
learning it's machine learning thing
changing it it's only purpose in life is
to create as much watch time as possible
you know and so it's kind of off doing
its own weird thing I guess in that in
that sense it's also it's almost
impressive that people do figure out by
observing like youtubers figure out how
it how its behaving yeah it's pretty
tough to nail down yes I still I've
almost gotten used to now the thing of
the new monetization does that happen to
you a lot it happens to me I don't know
if this is normal it happens on every
video I post to the point where I had
like a I got scared when it didn't
happen with this last video but then it
just took a day and then it became
but I just I'm used to clicking the
button my no review and it comes back in
like minutes usually from really okay I
don't understand okay case I don't know
what it is the triggers are getting to
monetize no matter what I do my face
must do it no I think it's normal like
our highlights channel pretty much 80%
of all the clips we post there get to
monetize and it's like every time I talk
to someone from YouTube delight it's
great like everyone's doing fine we keep
making improvements so it's eventually
but like when you post your video you
get the lion's share of your view but I
I think it says on there that you get
the they keep it and they give it to you
like if you're losing it during the time
really no I think there's no 50
monetized they don't show at all right
oh there's okay I think what you're
thinking about is copyright yeah yeah I
know that they do that for that but I
feel like I saw but yeah what you're
saying makes sense because there's no I
just wouldn't be odds yeah I want to
show you something that freaked me
they'll flip out there's some [ __ ] going
on in the world of digital digital
technology represent a normal real time
so they've got all this [ __ ] and this is
like its basic form have you seen this
yeah so this is called face to face
captures I don't know what RGB means but
these guys have made this real-time way
to make it look like you realistically
editing what people are saying so RGB
part is important that just means that
they're using nothing but the video
there's no special they're not using
like a 3d camera it's just a really
great algorithmic yeah they're just
whatever you could take any video at any
point and the other part the of the guy
you shoot with a regular webcam also its
RGB just means the picture no depth
information no nothing so have a look at
this it's the REE rendering of the math
interior to this end we recent this isuh
this is a real video of George pushing
this guy's just molarity face yeah it
still looks a little fishy cuz like well
first of all we know yeah
and second of all it still has room for
improvements because knowledge you're
able to generate a realistic and
convincing reenactment result is
unbelievable it looks really hear you
they have another video where their take
a speech of Obama yeah and basically
change
yeah and just completely change it with
another one of his speeches and I'm just
gonna show you guys brief as quick as I
can here given this audio ISO for
reference woman young people can stay up
tonight they take one speech about a
book stories you can cover a lot of
ground this is this one it looks for
he's giving a completely different
speech and they use this one here and
convert it onto this speech just to show
yes yes and they're not even using the
video they're just using the audio
they're making the audio move his mouth
Wow what is the point of this if not
like propaganda know that well that's
what's funny is that why are they
picking I guess they picked presidents
and stuff political figures yeah because
like maybe they thought that's the
footage that they give the longest
talking ads by I'm sure they could have
used theirs regular people that makes it
kind of ominous but um oh you said why
why I mean the the - from what I've
heard the Institute's and things this is
the work of several different usually
like colleges technological colleges
doing this research they're saying it's
like telepresence if you're like on a
submarine or something and you can't be
in a business meeting and for some
reason they have to see your face it's
like that seems completely but maybe
more the one that first video you were
showing the lady goes on to say like
they had they use an example where they
have like a translator like a
synchronous translator translating like
at the UN when they have the things in
their ear and they want to put the mouth
as if this is so important like put the
movements on the person speaking the
foreign language so it looks like
they're speaking does this kind of stuff
scare you at all do you are you afraid
of a world where people cuz right now
you're debunking all this stuff and to
you it's obvious are you afraid of a
world where stuff becomes so real that
it's impossible for anyone to know
including someone like you yeah I
wouldn't like that kind of world but
there are reasons why I don't I'm not
afraid of these particular examples this
technique this approach to it I don't
think is one of those things where you
can say this is gonna get better and
it's gonna be undetectable that because
what they're doing is in the end is like
retching pixels around the puppeteering
a piece of footage that is already
recorded right so you can I mean you
could see it with the naked eye and even
if they got the movements very natural
and realistic you'll still like you zoom
in you'll see like things are being just
a little it looks a little out of place
yeah I mean you you won't be able to
tell just by the what's the subject that
you're seeing but if you couldn't go in
like you'll see that like baked in
artifacts or whatever things are being
distorted after the facts after the fact
and you can like forensic really see
that with not a lot of I could do it you
know it's like the tools I look at
videos with but the new the more new
stuff with the machine learning is a
whole different thing and that's the one
where I would be concerned but also not
in the way that the scared the
fear-mongering that is kind of the way
that is being presented but it's more of
a thing to be on the fear-mongering
being like propaganda
well show in North Korea Obama saying
hey I want ya thank you or the more
practical thing of people making you
know porn celebrity a deep dig deep
fakes I never heard of it and then
someone texted me and I looked it up and
I actually it's crazy because it's being
banned everywhere like a thread is being
removed on one side it's been removed
but they found a way to take our famous
actresses or whoever's faces put it on a
similar figured porn star and did it
have you seen them know what it is yeah
it's it's like it looks real essentially
it looks like I haven't it looks pretty
real but what it is is is like their
shift it's no longer doing it through
like artistry is just shifting the whole
task to a machine so somebody put
together an algorithm or maybe it's a
conglomeration yes but it's not it's not
it's it's scarier than that because they
take you take a big library of images of
whatever person they I guess they use
celebrities because you can get a ton of
somebody's face and the more variety you
get of different examples
they're facing and how the lighting is
you feed it all into this algorithm
there's somebody literally made an app
that you can download and it's kind of
like it's primitive but it works you you
give all that to the machine to the
algorithm it looks at all the faces it
lines them up until it figures out what
this is and like it knows how to
position this face it creates like a
realistic digital mask of the person
then you just say take this point clip
track the face in this the same way and
now it's not just putting like footage
of a face it's putting this like
dynamically controlled digital
replication of the person so it looks
like disconcertingly real weirdly it
still looks like it looks fake now
because it's like the the resolution and
stuff is not there and you can see a lot
of artifacts from the reference photos
the views but it looks but at the same
time like the way it's integrated is
considering how new it is I was shocked
by how so this this is what scares you
more than like it scares me but at this
even here I like for a different reason
I'm not like on the rooftop shouting
like we're doomed
because this is it's true like when
artists when digital you know artists
and movies do stuff it's still human
decisions human-like touches and I as a
human or a captain disillusion whatever
he is can look and reverse-engineer that
and say this shadow shouldn't be there
whatever this is different because it's
true I agree that this is a case where
it's gonna get better and it's gonna
look flawless but you just have to shift
the task of checking if it's fake to the
same algorithm like I'm not I don't know
a lot about programming and data sight
machines yeah because I don't see why
the algorithm can't just be adapted to
just scan for what the algorithm did you
know because it's it would know better
than anybody sure so I I mean I don't
know if that's the way it would work but
I would a that's the way I would
approach the problem and it's like if
the as we're getting to the point where
you literally can say like computer get
Scarlett Johansson put her in this porn
clip and then you press of one button
and in a minute it gives you this
completely indistinguishable
thing that it's her you it that the day
we have that is the same day we'll have
another app in the absolute that says it
is this fake and the air porn is gonna
be off the changes in ten years
future made it guys to the future in in
one of your recent videos the gateway to
Sedona great video by the way god bless
you you take issue at the end with
people who blur the line between fact
and fiction under the guise of like hey
I'm just a troll and um and I'm just
trying to make a buck and make
entertainment right but you took issue
with that you think that it's more
harmful than that
so what exactly is the threat you see us
facing with people who blur that line
and aren't honest about them blurring
the line it's nice to know it's it's
hard enough to discern like what's real
just without people intentionally faking
stuff right like we're constantly and
evaluating our world using like science
to try to understand what's going on
around you know and connect all these
dots and make sure it's a consistent
model what's going on so why I don't
know why you would like do that on
purpose because like what I encountered
when I made that video is this this
whole there's this whole culture of
people who like this it has a name that
it's a it's um there's a thing there's a
subreddit yeah called interactive no
sleep where they tell fake or stories
that are supposed to be real and it's
against the rules to ever acknowledge or
be skeptical or to say hey that's fake
right it's like a full immersion well I
think I I mean I understand what is
meant by that but I don't understand why
my opinion is if it doesn't if your
story your the world that you're
building whatever doesn't work without
that one thing of you breaking you know
not acknowledging that it's fake then
it's that's the if that's the only thing
that makes it good then is it good like
why like why can't we have
because maybe there are examples of it
that are harmless but it's the same
device that like a hoaxer or someone
who's spreading misinformation like the
things that matter medical myths you
know and a vaccine things or whatever
like same thing same techniques so am I
just supposed to leave it up to the
Creator like you're an artist and you're
just telling your little ghost story you
have a ghost in your apartment but like
someone else is doing that the way that
that person is keeping up the reality of
it is the same exact techniques that
someone will use that's doing it in a
harmful way like nefarious so like why
you know why
maybe that's self-righteous or like no I
can see but it's it's a professional
lying in a way yeah like I just don't
see why like you cannot do that one
little asterisk to it and also like
people the way that some of this this
this immersive storytelling or whatever
it's called it's done is like it's not
done in some enclosed community like
someone will have a twitter or whatever
do or someone will have a YouTube
channel and then you can see from their
reactions that yeah there's I guess
there's a ton of people that get it that
are in on the thing and they're just
playing along and they love it that this
feels real but some people are there
because they're credulous of it and I I
say that I bet these like the creators
of these things like they depend on the
part of the entertainment is coming from
the fact that there are people walking
in on this unaware thinking it's real
and that's what gets there gives them
the goosebumps is they're getting
entertainment and that's weird to me
like why why why do you enjoy that
someone out there is getting fooled by
it for real you know like I said like
it's just we're leaving it in the
creator's hands if this is harmful or
innocent or like and I don't know is
that is the responsibility on the viewer
in a way I mean like this one video you
talk about this guy injecting sperm into
an egg yeah that's that's true I don't
know the answers like question it's like
good like yeah like I that one I have
almost a soft spot for the guy because
it's like even though he
very like the other examples I give they
don't talk to their audience to ignite
to say this is fake or not fake they
just don't engage but that guys like all
over his comments like people like
serious like scientists will say like
look this is how the thing works and he
will write a whole thing about like no
this is how science work actually you
didn't you don't know about this thing
in this book I'll just come he'll just
weave this like story just being very
committed yeah but it's at the same it's
against its said against this really
ridiculous like thing of him doing like
see the guys well no it's on you to
write it lives on your job well at any
rate this guy he takes an egg and he
makes a homunculus and it gets more wild
over and while he's got series one of
them being he it starts by him scoring
his semen on a syringe into an egg right
and it comes Yelp grows into some I read
human chicken yeah and he well so you
say that but like people say that's not
possible because those two things can't
mix but he'll he claims it's not
actually a hybrid I don't know what it
is yeah it's it's like a new species
that has like formed from just
spontaneous like the sperm just
encouraged it to form and it's not
inseminated it there's all these kids
around the world squirt injecting their
semen that's right that's the thing that
bothers me about like something like
there's this channel that I've always
make fun of called prank invasion and
this guy does kissing pranks where
they'll approach a girl and have like
hey you want to play a quick game for a
kit quick kiss let's play rock paper
scissor and if I win we get to make out
and he approaches his girls who are like
bikinis in the middle like at a beach or
something and all of a sudden they're
open mouth making out and it's clearly
staged but he'll never admit that it's
fake and his audience are all young kids
so he's creating a fleet of people who
are going out and doing like sexual
assault borderline and under the guise
that hey this is how the world works for
slick-ass cool it is and so for me
that's obviously harmful in that case
and here you definitely have fleets some
kids injecting their semen into act and
then if God knows what happens that
afterwards put it back they throw it out
he's a young kid he doesn't know but
maybe his mom cook that egg for
breakfast that's sick that's probably
happens though somewhere in the world
more than once
so 14 million views yeah so that this
actually has a really wide implication
on this make sure the line is clean
obviously of course I love the little
thing like it kind of is that when he
injects it like it displaces those you
make sure yolk or whatever if it comes
out of mic drips on his hand now let's
see the creature so in the creature show
up in this yeah so he breaks yeah he
Briggs the egg he makes it and the whole
thing like one little thing that made
this 14 million views is that there's a
little slow motion oh right right all
right this is me like if it was just
because I'm still that little touch it
gives you that I think movie but Legion
no I guess not
he didn't have to do much yeah that was
just some like but you like winning
yeah yeah right now when he like maybe
10 seconds from now
something some of those genius really
careful now that's a new species
so wait is it moving yeah as a little
tendril a little quiet yeah yeah so what
so what's going on right now well I mean
in this case like actually I looked at
all these guys those guys videos and as
far as I could tell I kind of later on
when he starts breeding them and doing
weird things semen and yeah like I
thought like maybe he was doing a little
3d stuff but I looked at it all kind of
closely and I realized that he is just
warping it's just warping of the image
kind of like the face warping yeah but
you know not like you took a little care
to like isolate the thing yeah ground
and move it around and I do it like I do
it and passing with a little toy in my
video like the principle that I exactly
the same I mean it looks good like
there's no I guess I'm not looking at it
closely but it's convincing it's a small
details done fine and he does although
like the designs of his Pokemon they're
pretty silly-looking like they're like
roleplay cartoons but I still does the
effects pretty carefully like it's
creative yeah yeah and that's like it's
creative it's almost like this very deep
satire maybe he's like yeah this is so
dumb like if you believe this this you
know yeah but yeah maybe not I don't
know I can't tell he's very it's
interesting [ __ ] you know I I didn't
know this should exist yeah this like a
Russian is a Russian for that guys
rushing YouTube there's like tons of
who's there yeah I don't I don't
frequented but I yeah there's a whole
its ass own world I guess really it what
is the best fake you've ever come across
during your career as Captain
disillusion well well I'll come that's
hard to answer but I think someone also
asked like a similar inverse thing which
is like what's a thing I was sure was
fake yes but I kind of like it cos fakes
I don't know like it's hard to nothing
stands out because it's all
part of the same you know process and
it's like someone does a little better
someone's a little more inventive with
it but it's this in my brain it's like a
sea of sameness but yeah like sometimes
I get I suffer from the same over
skepticism on things and people will
send me a video and I'm like this looks
so on its face fake that I just assume
it's fake and I started figuring it out
and I'm decide to make a video of it so
that the one I don't know from a year or
so ago someone passed around this thing
at like a water park where this guy
comes down this water slide and you know
you usually come down a water slide and
just fall into the pool but he just
continues to slide on the surface of the
water all the way to the edge of the
pool and just kind of get site using the
inertia that looks so ridiculous that I
was like okay I don't even have to check
I'm starting from the premise that this
is fake now how did they do it it's
weird because like as he transitions
from the water and Stanley sent me that
video again yeah there's a person
walking like a cross in front of camera
so it's like hiding the transition I'm
like obviously that's what you're all
your radars weird yeah it's like
tailor-made and it's kind of shot from
like one perspective point and even
though the cameras shaking it's kind of
just sitting in one place it's not
really motion but I started looking at
it and I'm like okay I'll try this I'll
look at this I stabilize it I'll look at
it you know at different speeds whatever
the standard things I start with and I'm
like you know what this is
I don't know this is starting to look
like there's nothing to grab on to at
all it should be simpler than there's
this kind of effect and then somebody
posted and I research what is this place
what it's like a Jamaican like resort or
something and then somebody posted
somebody else doing it from a different
angle from a slightly different angle I
know and then it's someone else had
performed the same trick yeah I don't
know if yeah I think it was a different
person but it's definitely a different
angle on the thing at the same park so
is there a possibility for Salah hold on
point of this this tweet has 14 million
let them fuse crazy slidin literally
into the dams like that's
no wonder has been seen so my time to
the okay so let's see here yeah ooh it
looks yeah it looks like a viral video
like it does like there's a difference
yeah or like the ads with the whatsit
the deodorant spice yeah Old Spice
that's just wow that's impressive either
way yeah and so is it possible that this
is just a that it was so good that it
fooled you it's possible but I wouldn't
bet on it
like just it starts to defeat the
purpose like I mean unless yeah maybe
someone will come on and say and explain
how they did it like what is it that
they got me on but I'm pretty sure just
from seeing the other versions of this
and like just reading up the fact that
this is just a weird thing also the way
he's just like yep I just did that yeah
I know and that kills me the little
transition of the person and then yeah
right in front of it and like you could
it looks strange because he hasn't his
shirt is completely off and then as the
lady passes it's like wow like it's so
is the perfect real thing yeah like it's
very misleading so that's one of the
ones where I'm like this this got me in
like the reverse way that's a great
video I give that yeah I think did you
get the captions sliding into the DMS is
there a fake that was so awful so bad
that convinced so many people that
sticks out in your mind I guess you know
back in the day yeah like the Penguins
like people used to really just want to
believe I guess or just they didn't know
any better but yeah that's probably like
the older the video the cheesier it is
that one is the oldest that was the one
that got you know that one I mean all of
those early videos I'm like it took me
like two seconds to figure out
everything about the video and there I
figured out how do I explain this over
five minutes to make it interesting you
mentioned once again I mentioned the
Sedonas video you mentioned at the end
the consequence of Burnt blurring the
lines between real and fake is stuff
like this government-funded UFO research
that was performed recently and they
were talking about it was from it's from
a while back but it's coveted that that
was funded for like twenty two million
dollars what agency was it I think it
was the Air Force some government agency
funded an actual investigation dat UFO
based on some evidence that they are
some video that they had it was just a
pet project of I forget the name of the
person but it was like this politician
who just thought he's a believer he's
into UFOs and he wanted to use a whole
department of an agency to I guess just
figure it out for him or whatever but
it's clear from the way he talks about
it that article that initially like kind
of brought attention to this they
they're pretty thorough and how they you
know did they're pretty fair to the
whole story and they explained like the
guy was into this like if that's like a
lot of people point to the fact that it
very existence of it is evidence that
something's out there well but like yeah
as we can see in the example of that
situation it's like if if it's if
someone up top decides that he must know
well nobody yeah but if if it's just a
decision by them then we can see how
it's one guy that ultimately got the
ball rolling but now it looks like oh
the an agency had department but it was
really just like this weird thing
somebody thought up and they had the
power to do it so it to me it says the
opposite it's like it's easy to look at
something established and say it's it's
like you know I I'm not you know there
are a lot of like skeptical bloggers and
podcasters that know this like general
cultural stuff like myths about Bigfoot
and UFOs and they you could they do a
good job explaining this stuff but you
can trace things like the fact that
there were literally no UFOs before like
1950 or whatever that became like
somebody faked a thing once like someone
used like a hubcap or whatever on a
string and then it just out where
someone wrote some novel where this was
described as a saucer
it's like it all stems from at that
point yeah and now in retrospect it
looks to us like oh it's always been a
things all you see wouldn't there be
something to this because everyone is
seeing saucer shaped things all over the
world but it's it's like a myth that
feeds on itself you can never trust this
you know interesting kind of thing
without looking back into the history
are there any conspiracy theories that
you believe is there any credible
conspiracy theories out there I guess I
don't follow like details like I'm sure
there's little person is there one yes
sirree like there's something there
probably like YouTube just shenanigans
like I don't know like yeah I would
probably be in the corporate world
there's more there's real kind of thing
yeah but I I don't I don't follow like
the political landscape and social
things to know like which ones look a
little more real to me than others but I
mean I'm not saying like conspiracies do
not occur you know we have the word for
a reason like yeah most definitely yeah
but it's become kind of a kind of a
mamey hasn't it here I'm gonna ask you
one last question
hmm this is customary of all of our
guests if you don't have a good answer
feel free to just say hey I have nothing
to say that's completely fine what could
this be
you're gonna be disappointed probably
because our fans you do notice go sorry
do you have any interesting ghost
stories paranormal experiences or
anything because well well because my
answer is because I knew that you asked
this I tried to think really what can I
know III yeah I tried I want to be fair
because everybody expects like gonna be
like nope yeah yeah that's fine I don't
have anything yeah well so the best I
mean I want to be fair I want to tell
you kind of a story like a highlight
reel of several things and you tell me
okay that was a kid that was a little
kid like second grade we had this weird
schedule where our classes would be in
the afternoon so we'd be at school too
late at night when he gets dark and one
time we're in recess and we're like our
classroom is at the end of a hallway
with a stairwell where it's the lights
are out and
dark and it's kind of creepy and red at
recess and one of our classmates says oh
you know I know this like thing where
you say these incantations if you do it
in the middle of the night in a dark
place and that's quiet you can summon
like UFOs and aliens from another
dimension
and we're like cool let's do this and we
go into the dark stairwell and he starts
creepily like sitting and just saying
alien things in language and it's like
we're standing there and watching this
guy speak in tongues and then it started
starting this feeling starts to come
over us like some shits gonna go down
right now like I feel the presence of
the thing right smash cut to a few years
later I'm still a kid but I'm like in my
neighborhood I had a best friend where
we would like get into trouble crawl
into people's backyards and you know
going go into construction sites and
whatever and he found out that we can
get into the Attic of this creepy
looking apartment building that we lived
in front of and that had this big
communal it was like from the 30s oh it
was a normal apartment building but kind
of creepy and we found out we can get
into the Attic which had no windows it
was just this crazy space we walked in
there it's pitch black and it's lit only
by like a couple of pinpricks in the
ceiling just to give you enough light to
know that there's a space here and
there's like objects that I can't make
out they could be monsters or whatever
we thought maybe it's haunted we don't
know what we're gonna find there so we
creep in and it's like completely silent
you know that silence that's like it's
deafening in your ears it starts to make
that noise and we're like creeping
through creeping through making little
creaks nothing and then suddenly
something pops out of the wall like kind
of from above and just shoots at us with
like this menacing like hiss and just
flies right at us
okay smash cut - I love I'm I love
building suspense now I'm a pimply
teenager in high school I'm already in
America now and I'm into martial arts
and Bruce Lee movies and I got this book
on kung-fu and I'm like it talks about
you know kicking and punching but also
there's this section on what Shaolin
masters
the amazing feats they could work out
and like you could keep raised like
picking up a big pot that you keep
filling up gradually until your hand
becomes so strong you can rip people's
throats out
or you can learn to control your muscles
over years until you can pull your
testicles into your body to avoid it
kicks to the groin yeah or you can like
rub your some sand in a basin until like
and let it run through your fingers
until eventually over years of practice
you just rub your hands in front of the
sand and you start to make the sand move
and yadda yadda yadda you have
telekinetic powers to attack people at a
distance and I'm like that's the one
I'll take that one
I'll practice for years now I'll do this
I get some sand from the beach and I and
I was on my way and practicing this so
what do you think the climax of each of
these stories is can you guess I don't
know I'm wait for this match well the
cushion cut back so the smash cut to the
first the classmate in the stairwell we
just stood there for four minutes until
nothing was happening
we got creeped out standing in a dark
place and we just left we just ran back
to the class the aliens didn't show up
all right the thing with the friend in
in the Attic the thing the entity flew
at us stopped like hovered fell down and
waddled away it was a pigeon like we
scared the pigeon and I regret to tell
you that I did not after years of
practice yeah well I kind of probably
just spent a week rubbing some sand but
I did not have telekinetic progress that
was a great that was like an anti go
story my point in explaining and telling
you that is that I don't want to I'm not
like a naysayer like I have a track
record in my life of trying to find this
phenomenon I'm down I was always like a
scared child like I was scared of the
dark I was scared of aliens shows or
whatever but I was curious enough to
want to see these things and I tried
I've done my due diligence yeah bring it
on that's what I say bring it on well
we'll both
waiting and until then everybody go
subscribe and watch Captain disillusion
on YouTube and when you're done and when
you realize he's the best Channel and
YouTube go to his patreon and support
him there thank you thank you so much
for coming out
gracing us it was a joy as a pleasure
god bless you guys are amazing
remember guys rhett and Link on Thursday
and Tuesday we have another episode and
I hope that kid Jordans not calling back
any more time I hate that kid guys thank
you so much for watching I hope you have
a wonderful weekend thanks for spending
your time with us got blessing people in
Europe they get angry when I say have a
great evening cuz it's morning for them
so shadows all my girl boys anyway guys
have a great weekend
whatever time of day it is god bless you
see you on Thursday
Tata